I just learned about the edge
sorting uh thing that uh Phil Ivey maybe
others were involved with
I just reading it at first was super
interesting to me that you can exploit
the imperfections in the printing of
cards yeah that was almost cool to me
that that was that's almost not cheating
because it's like that needs to be a
movie
yes yes what happened with Phil Ivey in
that whole case is it's it's a
catastrophe really yeah it is such a
horrible precedent because here's what
he did Phil Ivey shows up at the casino
says I want to play this game they say
okay all right I want to play with those
decks they say okay they agree to
everything that he says he never touches
the cards he doesn't do anything outside
of the fact that you cards that you
supplied have imperfections on them and
he can see them yeah okay so that
increases his chances of winning he
could still lose theoretically right
probably not but he can lose in theory
he just gives him a little bit of an
edge and it's all stuff based on what
you provided yeah so the idea that you
offered a game I accepted I beat you and
now you want to free roll me that's
disgusting so for people who don't know
maybe you can elaborate and it's just
fascinating to me but you're exploiting
the imperfections and the card patterns
on the back and then they look different
if you rotate it and the the fascinating
thing too when you Shuffle usually you
don't rotate the cards so that you can
see the in sort of detect which cards
are the strong cards by marking them by
through rotating them and the way you
know they're rotate is because of the
pattern imperfections yeah so some of
the cards like you said like you know
they have those like the that that
pattern on it yeah and some of them this
was faulty cards on there we're not cut
properly yeah so like the eights and
nines had the card cut differently and
those are important cards in this game
you know the eights and nines or
whatever so you could essentially from
looking at the back of the card discern
you know what it's going to be you do
nothing in terms of like cheating
yourself you're not rigging the game all
you're doing is taking advantage of the
fact that you're playing you know you've
offered me cards that yeah are faulty
can I just say that of course it would
be Phil Ivey who's who's the goat at the
at the normal game it would be figure
out this particular thing I mean that's
what if you're into soccer this Diego
Maradona has that famous hand of God in
the World Cup where he scores a goal
with his hand and uh so of course the
the referee didn't see it they thought
it was a header so I mean part of the
part of the magic of the genius of the
people at the top of the game is they're
able to exploit
all the flaws that are there it's that's
a beautiful place he feels like Phil had
you know in his Heyday he had he
exploited weaknesses and casinos you
know systems all over the country like
in one night I don't know if you know
the story and one night he would take a
plane a private plane and fly to 30
different casinos all over the country
because he would have these deals where
they're like all right we got this Big
Rich sucker who's going to come here and
play craps and he's going to lose all
our money so he'd have this deal with
one of the casinos where they'd be like
all right you get 20 back up to half a
million right so if you lose half a
million we'll give you back 100K okay so
he'd go to one Casino in Tunica he'd
play half a million win win or lose
you know he would leave they think
they're going to get him to stay they
get him a big room whatever so let's say
he goes to Tunica he lose half a million
okay now he goes he flies to Atlantic
City he wins half a million okay he lost
half a million and one one half a
million but he got a hundred thousand
back so he's actually plus 100 000. do
that at 10 casinos a night you're making
a million dollars in free equity and
they would give him promotional chips
and all these kind of things and free
flights and stuff like that so he took
advantage of the image yeah you know
that they're trying to exploit so this
is why I don't have any empathy for
these casinos because there's giving you
free drinks they're giving you why do
you think they're doing that kind of the
kindness of their heart they're trying
to exploit you so guess what you lost at
your own game pay the piper and I think
it was crazy because the judges in his
case said
he did not cheat but well we it's
probably not right hold on yeah you just
said he didn't cheat you know that that
should be the end of the case